politique bonsoir et bienvenue dans les
deux politiques votre rendez-vous
politique du dimanche soir sur Radio
sensation en association avec TV 78 et
pour cet épisode 224 nous allons
direction l'Assemblée nationale mon
invité la députée renaissance des
Hauts-de-Seine constance le grip
politique
bonsoir constance les grippe bonsoir
vous êtes député renaissance de la
sixième circonscription des
Hauts-de-Seine ne circonscription qui a
notamment élu 4 fois Nicolas Sarkozy
comme député vous êtes aussi conseillère
municipal de Neuilly-sur-Seine longtemps
membre de la droite de l'UDF de l'UMP
puis des républicains qui étaient votre
famille politique lorsque vous étiez
député européenne entre 2010 et 2017
vous avez été élu ensuite une première
fois députée à l'Assemblée nationale en
2017 sous l'étiquette LR puis 5 ans
après cette année vous êtes engagés avec
la majorité prévisionielles derrière
Emmanuel Macron nous allons aborder avec
vous ce soir plusieurs sujets
l'actualité internationale avec la
situation en Ukraine nous évoquerons
aussi rapidement les dernières lois à
voter par l'Assemblée nationale puis
plus en détail le PLF 2023 dont l'examen
a débuté cette semaine mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est aussi cette grève dans
les raffineries depuis plusieurs jours
les Français galèrent à trouver de
l'essence conséquence du blocage donc
des raffineries par les salariés de
Total et se déceaux qui réclament une
augmentation de salaire alors c'est
tombé cette semaine la réquisition a été
demandée des salariés par la première
ministre est-ce qu'il doit selon vous
l'État doit employer la force pour
remettre la situation remettre de
l'ordre dans la situation
en tout cas l'État prend ses
responsabilités vous l'avez rappelé une
première réquisition a été décidée par
la première ministre cette semaine pour
faire face à la situation de blocage que
nous jugeons parfaitement inadmissibles
orchestrée par
un certain syndicats la CGT pour ne pas
la nommer aussi bien dans les dépôts et
raffineries de l'emprise totale que les
dépôts et raffinerie de l'entreprise
Esso Essonne dans la mesure où il y a eu
conclusion d'un accord salarial qui a
été signé par les syndicats majoritaires
au sein de la société Esso Essonne il a
été jugé parfaitement irresponsable que
un syndicat au sein de l'entreprise Esso
exon la CGT pour encore une fois nommé
ce syndicat continue malgré la
conclusion d'un accord
favorable et reconnu comme tel par les
syndicats majoritaires continuent de
pratiquer le blocage et d'empêcher la
sortie du carburant et donc c'est à
l'encontre de cette première opération
de blocage qui se poursuit que la
réquisition a été prononcée il s'agit
pas d'une réquisition générale la
réquisition d'une part et très encadré
par la loi ça doit être précis et encore
une fois très très encadré c'est
forcément temporaire mais le
gouvernement ne peut pas tolérer que
perdure une situation de blocage et des
difficultés d'approvisionnement très
importantes pour nos compatriotes c'est
dommageable pour la vie quotidienne de
nos Français de nos compatriotes qui
vraiment galère à trouver du carburant
c'est dommageable pour certaines
activités économiques et donc il était
de la responsabilité du gouvernement de
ne pas laisser nos compatriotes être
pris en otage en quelque sorte par un
conflit entre un syndicat de la CGT et
la direction de grandes entreprises et
de faire face à cette situation avec la
panoplie d'instruments qui est à la
disposition du gouvernement pour faire
cesser ce blocage donc nous espérons que
progressivement
à la suite des différentes mesures
enclenchées je rappelle que ça n'est pas
que la réquisition qui compose la
panoplie
d'outils dont dispose le gouvernement il
y a eu aussi le déblocage d'une partie
de nos réserves stratégiques et nous
pourrions envisager de poursuivre le
déblocage de d'autres fractions de nos
réserves stratégiques il y a la mise en
place aussi d'autres
modalités d'approvisionnement sur le sur
le territoire pour contourner les
difficultés logistiques il y a aussi la
priorisation parce que toutes les
stations services ne sont pas privées de
carburant et ne sont pas privés de tous
les types de carburants donc on peut
aussi et ça a été demandé au préfet de
mettre en place des fils prioritaires
pour certaines professions publiques et
pour les soignants notamment les
ambulanciers les infirmiers infirmières
les médecins qui doivent se déplacer
impérativement toute une panoplie de
mesure et déployée nous sommes
conscients de la situation de grandes
difficultés et de tension qui est ainsi
engendré chez nos compatriotes et nous
apprend vraiment chacun et chacune à
faire preuve de responsabilité que ce
soit les syndicats représentant les
personnels des deux sociétés que vous
avez nommées aussi bien que la direction
de ces deux entreprises mais encore une
fois je rappelle qu'il y a eu un accord
salarial qui a été conclu
favorablement et signé par les syndicats
majoritaires chez Esso exon et que la
direction de Total a
sous notamment la pression assez
insistante de l'exécutif accepté de
commencer beaucoup plus tôt que ce
qu'elle avait initialement laissé
entendre commencer les discussions salir
salariale donc nous espérons que tout
cela portera ses fruits assez rapidement
mais encore une fois il n'est pas
question de tolérer le blocage
l'actualité internationale aussi est
dense Moscou à bombardé à nouveau la
capitale ukrainienne ce lundi qui est
n'avait pas été touché depuis plusieurs
mois par les bombardements la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale il y a LeBron
privé c'était rendu à Kiev d'ailleurs
fin septembre pour signer un protocole
d'accord avec le président du parlement
ukrainien Ruslan Stephen Chuck alors
pour développer des échanges dans la
durée entre les parlementaires notamment
dans le cadre de la candidature de
l'Ukraine a lieu alors est-ce que selon
vous c'est le chemin qui doit être
choisi l'Ukraine à selon vous vocation à
entrer dans l'Union européenne dans les
années à venir
ah je suis tout à fait formelle pour moi
l'Ukraine a une véritable perspective
européenne fait d'ailleurs déjà parti je
dirais de la famille de cœur de l'Europe
au sens large et à tout à fait vocation
à rejoindre un jour l'Union européenne
en tout cas nous Français et nous
membres de la majorité présidentielle et
parlementaire à l'instar du président
Macron et des membres du gouvernement a
commencé par Catherine Colonna et
Laurence boule nous appuyons là qu'en
nature de l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne
alors qu'il s'agit pas d'avoir des
procédures accélérées de faire les
choses dans la précipitation vous le
savez les dossiers de candidature sont
examinés très longuement et implique la
mise en place de toutes mes séries de
réforme souvent très profondes et très
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre dans les
pays qui sont candidats je rappelle que
la dernière adhésion à l'Union
européenne se fait celle de la Croatie
et que le processus de la Croatie a mis
10 ans je ne peux pas préjugé d'ores et
déjà du laps de temps qu'il sera
nécessaire de voir se dérouler pour la
candidature de l'Ukraine mais enfin ce
n'est pas dans l'immédiat que l'Ukraine
va entrer dans l'Union européenne encore
une fois elle a à faire face à une
guerre terrible vous avez rappelé les
nouveaux bombardements extrêmement
massif de la Russie voilà sur la
capitale à nouveau touché mais sur tout
le territoire ce sont des
infrastructures importantes bien sûr
aussi mais surtout et encore des
populations civiles qui sont ciblés et
qui sont je dirais de manière tout à
fait volontaire et consciente ciblées
par les frappes russes il y aura après
parce qu'il y aura un après pour
l'Ukraine bien sûr il y aura la fin de
la guerre et le retour de la paix il y
aura un long travail la reconstruction a
mener mais clairement pour nous le crâne
a vocation à intégrer la grande famille
politique européenne et intégrée l'Union
européenne et je réaffirme tout notre
soutien
à l'Ukraine aux autorités
ukrainiennes à son armée vous savez que
la France comme les autres pays
européens et très présente pour aider
les forces armées ukrainiennes à faire
face à l'agression militaire russe et
nous appelons ardemment et bien les uns
et les autres à accroître leur soutien
et leur aide militaire
budgétaires
humanitaire logistique la France qui a
d'ailleurs
emmené plusieurs chars en Roumanie cette
semaine des chars Leclerc le 1er débat
de là
le premier débat de l'Assemblée
nationale la cette session de rentrée
c'était d'ailleurs sur l'Ukraine l'Union
européenne a encore accentué les
sanctions sur la route la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine et pourtant Vladimir
Poutine continue est-ce que c'est
sanctions elles sont efficaces les
sanctions produisent leurs effets ce
sont des sanctions de nature
essentiellement économique et bancaire
elle produisent leurs effets sur
l'économie russe le système bancaire
russe et quasi
intégralement exclu du système bancaire
Swift des changes
interbancaires il y a de réelles
difficultés d'approvisionnement pour
dépend entier de l'industrie russe qui
ne peut plus bénéficier ne peut plus
acheter toute une série d'équipements ce
qui
engendre un effondrement la production
industrielle russe et des cascades en
faillite je rappelle également que le
départ des grandes entreprises
internationales a également provoqué de
graves difficultés donc la chute du PIB
russe elle est là et elle est bien là
alors bien sûr les statistiques
produites par le régime russe en matière
économique sont souvent au sujet à
caution mais nous avons des
renseignements et nous constatons qu'il
y a une aggravation de la situation
économique et sociale réelle et que donc
les sanctions qui frappent l'économie
russe qui frappe les entreprises russes
qui frappent les banques russes et qui
frappent aussi et de plus en plus
fortement
un nombre croissant d'oligarques de
soutien du régime de membres de
l'entourage de Vladimir Poutine de
Vladimir Poutine lui-même dont vous le
savez les avoir
à l'extérieur du territoire russe sont
gelés tout cela produit ses effets les
effets sont toujours
longs les effets sont toujours lents à
se produire mais il se produisent et
inévitablement il rentre plus difficile
il rentre plus difficile pour le régime
de Poutine le financement de l'effort de
guerre l'ensemble du continent européen
était réuni à Prague
à l'exception donc de la Biélorussie et
de la Russie donc c'était pour lancer un
nouveau forum diplomatique la communauté
politique européenne 44 dirigeant
présent suite à la volonté d'Emmanuel
Macron d'intégrer les pays non membres
de l'UE dans le débat dans la discussion
et pour montrer aussi que tout le
continent était uni face à Vladimir
Poutine l'objectif est de faire
patienter aussi les pays qui souhaitent
rentrer dans l'UE par exemple les pays
des Balkans notamment qui poussent
depuis très longtemps pour une
intégration Emmanuel Macron a dit devant
le Parlement européen le 9 mai dernier
que leur chemin était déjà tracé c'est
votre sentiment à vous aussi alors
j'étais à Strasbourg dans l'enceinte du
Parlement européen lorsqu'il est
effectivement le prix dans Macron dans
le discours qui venait conclure les
travaux de ce qu'on appelle la
conférence l'avenir de l'Europe a tracé
la perspective de cette communauté
politique européenne c'est en fait une
idée qui a déjà quelques dizaines
d'années une très belle idée qu'enfin le
président Macron a remise sur la table
et d'une manière c'est vraiment
convaincante pour entraîner dans un
premier temps ses partenaires chefs
d'État également de l'Union européenne
et puis ensuite plus globalement les
pays européens qui nous entourent nos
grands voisins nos grands et nos petits
voisins c'est un moment très important
que la naissance de cette communauté
politique européenne elle a vocation
effectivement vous employez l'expression
forum diplomatique à être un grand forum
diplomatique dans lequel se retrouvent
les pays actuellement membres de l'Union
européenne un centre de pays qui sont
effectivement candidats pour certains
depuis longtemps à l'entrée dans l'Union
européenne des pays qui ne sont pas
candidats et qui ne le seront peut-être
jamais un pays qui est sorti de l'Union
européenne je fais partie voilà celles
et ceux qui se réjouissent voir le
Royaume-Uni participé aux rencontres la
communauté politique européenne et
l'idée est d'organiser un nouveau cercle
européen un grand cercle je dirais à
l'échelle du continent
gouvernement représentant 44 pays qui
effectivement ont en partage incontinent
donc une géographie une histoire une
histoire souvent tragique jalonnée de
guerre civile et surtout un destin et un
avenir commun on va y parler
sécurité
énergies d'autres grands sujets seront
progressivement mis à l'ordre du jour je
pense que c'est très important
effectivement qu'il y ait cet espace de
dialogue qui pourra déboucher sur des
projets
communs qui viendront travailler à
garantir la paix et la stabilité et la
sécurité au sens large du continent
européen nous en avons grandement besoin
de cette communauté politique européenne
ce sont donnés rendez-vous à nouveau en
2023 au printemps en Moldavie pour
poursuivre donc ces discussions mais
l'Europe c'est toujours beaucoup de
tensions Emmanuel Macron s'est félicité
de voir se rencontrer pour la la
première fois par exemple le Premier
ministre arménien avec le président turc
erdouane le conflit entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan est moins médiatisé que le
conflit ukrainien est pourtant il y a de
vives tensions alors pourquoi est-ce que
on en parle un petit peu moins de ce
qu'on fait alors je vais juste vous
reprendre s'agissant de ce qui se passe
actuellement en Arménie c'est pas tant à
conflit entre l'Arménie laservation je
dirais qu'une guerre d'agression menée
par le régime azéri le régime du
président Alif contre l'Arménie voilà le
parallèle peut éventuellement être fait
avec effectivement l'agression et la
guerre menée par le régime de Poutine
contre contre l'Ukraine voilà il y a pas
des hostilités entre deux pays il y a
une véritable agression menée par le
régime à l'if contre contre l'Arménie et
et des frappes sur le sol même de
l'Arménie qui touche non seulement les
soldats Arméniens mais également les
populations
civiles vous me posez la question de
savoir pourquoi est-ce que ce conflit
est moins médiatisé entre
dans les médias peut-être et et moi sur
les écrans radars que le conflit entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie et la guerre
d'agression menée par la Russie en
Ukraine c'est plutôt médias qu'il faut
poser la question évidemment c'est plus
loin le Caucase c'est plus loin c'est
une région du monde compliquée dont les
tenants et aboutissants sont quelquefois
complexes à maîtriser en tout cas pas
parler chancellerie mais peut-être par
par l'opinion publique et les médias
nous appelons nous au sein de la
majorité présidentielle et parlementaire
et nous avons eu l'occasion d'en parler
avec
les ministres du Quai d'Orsay à ce que
la France affirme et réaffirme toujours
avec beaucoup de force et de chaleur je
dirais
son amitié avec l'Arménie soit du côté
de l'Arménie
vous le savez le président Macron c'est
beaucoup entremi effectivement pour
qu'il y ait une rencontre à Prague entre
le Premier ministre arménien et le
président alief personne n'est dupe et
personne n'est naïf et le président
Macron est certainement ni naïf ni dupe
mais à réussir à faire accepter par les
deux parties et notamment donc par
l'Azerbaïdjan qui mène cette guerre
d'agression contre l'Arménie la présence
d'une mission européenne une mission
civile qui viendra sur place constater
un centre de choses collecter pourquoi
pas à ce moment de fait et commencer à
jouer un rôle non pas d'interposition
mais en tout cas
voir si elle peut jouer sur le terrain
parce que la question des frontières qui
est assez sensible
un rôle
de médiation et et de pacification c'est
une première
initiative concrète apportée au crédit
de la France au crédit notamment de
cette enceinte diplomatique que
représente la communauté politique
européenne mais nous appelons notre pays
la France les autres chefs d’état le
gouvernement européens à effectivement
ne jamais passer
au second voire au troisième plan ce qui
se passe en Arménie et l'agression menée
par le régime du président alief à
l'encontre du peuple arménien redonnons
en France à présent avec un gros morceau
qui vous attend à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est le projet de loi de finance 2023
plus couramment appelé le PLF donc le
but c'est de voter le budget pour
l'année qui vient
tout d'abord donc il s'agit de prévoir
les recettes de répartir les dépenses en
fonction des différents ministères vous
êtes vous siégé au sein de la commission
des finances ça fait des semaines que
vous travaillez sur sur ce PLF comment
sont passés les premiers échanges en
commission
alors en commission les échanges ont été
je dirais nourri
animée mais avec toujours une bonne
tenue de manière générale et les débats
en commission bien qu'ils soient filmés
et mis en permanence et en direct sur le
site internet de l'assemblée par exemple
étant néanmoins médiatisé que ce qui se
passe dans l'enceinte de l'hémicycle
sont moins voilà sont moins propices aux
éclats de voix au coup aux grandes
diatrices open Shine pourquoi pas donc
les débats ont été des débats de bonne
tenue sans sans aucune
concession mais nous avons pu en nous
écoutant et en ayant les uns et les
autres une attitude respectueuse faire
prévaloir nos arguments nous avons nous
la majorité parlementaire les trois
groupes de la majorité entendu le contre
projet les contre-propositions faites de
manière assez dispersée d'ailleurs mais
c'est normal parce qu'elles sont
différentes les différentes oppositions
le débat était un débat de bonne tenue
mais nous avons dû je dirais
souvent tenir nos positions et nous
battre pied à pied pour que des
dispositions importantes que nous
concernant comme importante introduite
dans le projet loi de finance
2023 par l'exécutif ne soit pas
bah tu en bref ne vont pas toujours
obtenu gain de cause mais nous avons
essayé de faire prévaloir nos nos
arguments sur ce budget qui est un
budget très responsable un budget de
protection des enjeux
énergétiques les enjeux internationaux
les enjeux économiques actuels nous
amènent à
privilégier la poursuite de la
protection des Français la protection de
leur pouvoir d'achat la protection
contre l'inflation en prolongeant par
exemple bouclier tarifaire pour les
tarifs des gaz et d'électricité c'est un
budget de protection c'est un budget
responsable qui ne va peut-être pas
aussi loin que certains pourraient le
souhaiter dans la réduction de la
dépendance biblique de déficits mais
nous avons fait le
choix d'un chemin de crête étroit c'est
vrai ou nous commençons
plus de dépenses et votre ancienne
famille politique les LR qui ne le
voteront pas car ils jugent trop
dépensier oui les républicains nous ont
fait savoir qui trouvaient le projet de
budget présenté par le Gouvernement et
la majorité trop dépensier mais ils
peinent en réalité il faut le
reconnaître ils peine à mettre en avant
des propositions très précises et très
solide et très chiffré sur la réduction
de la dépense publique qu'ils appellent
de leurs nous nous faisons face encore
une fois en responsabilité
aux situations difficiles dans lequel se
trouve plongée et bien des Français nous
continuons à les protéger contre
l'inflation je le rappelle et c'est
important que vous auditeurs étaient les
spectateurs le sachent c'est en France
que l'inflation est la plus basse
on la compare ce qui est dans tous les
autres pays de l'Union européenne grâce
au bouclier tarifaires mis en place par
l'exécutif et que nous projeons et
évidemment ça a un coût mais ça nous
semble être important et malgré cela
malgré cette volonté de continuer à
protéger donc de continuer à dépenser de
l'argent pour protéger les Français et
leur garantir le maintien de leur
pouvoir d'achat nous arrivons à
décélérer le rythme d'accroissement de
la dépense publique donc c'est encore
une fois une ligne de crête assez
étroite mais nous arrivons à la tenir
quelques chiffres sur ce budget sur le
budget de certains ministères en tout
cas le projet prévoit donc de passer
donc de 14,5 à 20,7 milliards d'euros le
ministère du Travail le budget de son
budget le budget de l'Éducation
nationale lui sera augmenté et passe de
56,5 milliards à 60,2 milliards avec une
enveloppe pour revaloriser le salaire
des enseignants le ministère de défense
voit ses crédit augmenter lui aussi plus
de 3 milliards d'euros dans un contexte
on l'a rappelé international très
incertains alors les oppositions ont
déjà annoncé qu'elles ne vaut pas donc
il ne reste finalement qu'une seule
option le 49-3 alors les oppositions
avant même que nous démarrions les
débats et l'examen de nos textes
budgétaires en commission des finances
avaient fait savoir effectivement
qu'elle souhaitait voter contre le
budget que nous proposons à la France et
donc effectivement
nous sommes obligés de constater qu'il
n'y a plus guère d'attitude constructive
et qu'il nous faudra certainement faire
face en responsabilité à la situation de
blocage qui risque de se manifester dans
l'hémicycle simplement moi je tiens à
rappeler effectivement que
en plus que de la volonté de protéger
les Français contre les aléas
économiques et les aléas de l'inflation
mondiale ce budget est un budget
qui privilégie le réarmement régalien
qu'une forte augmentation effectivement
des budgets du Miss à la justice du
ministère intérieur et donc c'est pas
des augmentations
plus de gendarmes pour donner plus de
moyens à la justice afin qu'elle arrive
à accomplir sa mission de manière plus
rapide je crois que c'est une vraie
attente de le compatriotes et plus
efficace nous avons également
privilégié l'éducation tout cela ça a un
coût bien évidemment mais ça correspond
à des priorités politiques fortes et
nous regrettons vivement que les
oppositions toutes les oppositions en
décrétant qu'elles avaient voter contre
le budget vont voter contre le
réarmement régalien vont voter contre
l'augmentation de la rémunération des
enseignants on contre la poursuite du
bouclier tarifaire mais encore une fois
les institutions étant ce qu'elles sont
si nous constatons une situation de
blocage caractérisée dans l'hémicycle du
Palais Bourbon et bien nous ferons face
à nous responsabilités et nous agirons
conformément à ce que la Constitution
permet pour sortir d'une situation de
blocage il faut que les Français soient
tout à fait je dirais assuré ou rassurer
sur ce point-là il y aura un budget pour
2023 et pour la fin de cette émission
nous allons passer à une dernière
question d'actualité locale
toujours avec constance le grip depuis
tes Renaissance la sixième
circonscription des Hauts-de-Seine en
450 millions d'euros voici le trou
financier qu'il reste à boucher selon
les estimations de Valérie Pécresse la
présidente les républicains de la région
Île-de-France et présidente aussi du
syndicat
Île-de-France mobilité l'ancienne
candidate à l'élection présidentielle a
demandé à l'état de reprendre la dette
covid de 2 milliards euros d'IDF
mobilité alors dans un contexte en plus
extrêmement compliqué avec une pénurie
de de chauffeurs depuis la rentrée
est-ce que l'État doit venir en aide à
EDF mobilité selon vous alors il faut
quand même rappeler que l'État sait déjà
mobilisé et déjà venu en aide en soutien
à la région
Île-de-France de manière extrêmement
forte
aussi bien pendant la crise covid que
depuis c'est une région bien sûr la plus
grande de notre pays mais qui est déjà
considérablement soutenu et aider par
l'État moi je ne suis pas dans le détail
des discussions et des négociations qui
se déroulent depuis quelques temps entre
d'un côté la région Île-de-France et de
l'autre côté le gouvernement et et à
sombre de ministre mais je crois que sur
cette matière comme sur d'autres il faut
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités
l'État a déjà beaucoup beaucoup soutenus
budgétairement fin la région
Île-de-France donc avec l'argent des
contribbles Français de tous les
contréables Français donc il y a un
moment où nous pourrons certainement pas
aller au-delà de ce que nous avons déjà
fait donc il faut certainement aller
plus loin dans les économies et au sein
du syndicat et le France mobilité il y a
certainement d'autres manières de faire
face à la dette importante de cette
entité merci beaucoup constance d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
la député renaissance de la sixième
circonscription des Hauts-de-Seine et
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de lobe de
politique
[Musique]